how are you feeling skip a some retired
[Music]
and can you tell me a bit about the
child
it's a boy that's what yeah
I named him after my own son
[Music]
maybe I asked his name
what are conditions like in the camp
right now sweetie it's okay you know I
get fed I have a heater now so you know
it's kind of difficult going around
doing stuff yourself switch that I have
a child
will you be able to care for him here
it's gonna be a bit difficult because
right now I have one is because people
without money it's kind of hard to get
around you know with the amount of
things they give us
his life in the camp better than it was
in Babu's over the last past over the
last few months definitely I mean I'm
not starving I have a roof over my head
you know before I was sleeping outside
and there was no medical care so
everyone was getting sick my kids died
because of sickness
you have obviously been through a lot
over the last year's
could you describe for us what it has
been like to live with an under Islamic
state
you know at first it was nice it was
like other no shoulder in the videos
like come make family together then
afterwards things got harder you know
only loss Raqqa we had to keep moving
and moving and moving in situation
before
was there a point where you started to
have second thoughts about your life in
Islamic state under Islamic state just
only at the end after my son died and I
realized I took out for the sake of our
children the sake of my daughter and my
baby it was only at the end it was only
at the end but you didn't have any
regrets up until that point
what was it about Islamic state that
attracted you what did you like about it
the way they showed how you can go
they'll take care of you you can have
your own family there you can do
anything you're living under Islamic law
[Music]
did you know what Islamic state we're
doing when you left for Syria because
they had beheaded people there were
executions those things and I was I was
okay with it at first because you know I
want I started becoming religious really
just just before I left you know from Y
heard that islamically that is all
allowed so I was okay with that you
didn't question that
there's a struggle going on in the UK
now at home belt whether you should be
allowed to come home or not you know
that what is what are your feelings
about that I think a lot of people
should have like sympathy towards me for
everything I've been through you know
and I there I I didn't know why I was
going into and I left and I just was
hoping that maybe for me a foot sick of
me and my child
let them come back
because I can't live in this camp
forever
[Music]
the head of the foreign intelligence
services in the UK says people like you
are potentially very dangerous what
would you say to him they don't have any
evidence against me doing anything
dangerous when I went to Syria I was
just housewife in time four years
stayed home to care about him to care of
my kids I never did anything dangerous
and in May pork and I never encouraged
people become cereal so it only have
proof that I did anything that is
dangerous your family have made an
appeal for you to come home they are
pleading with the British government to
allow you to come home
do you have a message for your family
just keep trying to get me back I really
don't stay here I don't take care of my
child in his camp because I'm afraid he
might even die in this camp
[Music]
what do you think life would be like
back in the UK I don't know because I
know there would be a lot of
restrictions on me I wouldn't be afraid
to do things like they used to be able
to do I don't know if they'll take my
child away all these things this is kind
of one of my biggest priorities my child
because I left because of him
so I would want him to be taken away
from me he's trying to live their life
if the authorities took the child away
from you would you accept that it would
be hard to accept I would try my best to
keep him with me I don't see any reason
why they would take away from me I don't
think there are concerns because of what
you have have been through views that
people feel you may have or still have
in regard to is that next day
something they have to question me about
before they take my child away I guess
one question that people are asking is
whether you can be rehabilitated you
know it would be really hard everything
I've been through you know I'm still I'm
still kind of in the mentality of dolar
you know planes of my head and having
the emergency backpack and starving and
all these things it would be a really
big shock go back to the UK
yeah may I ask what was it that
attracted you was it from watching
videos was there somebody or who
recruited you or a cleric who recruited
you what was it that prompted a 15 year
old girl to go to Syria during the time
I left you no dollar was on the news and
stuff and like a lot of videos were
coming out and I saw the videos on the
internet and I just kind of attracted me
to them they attracted a lot of people
do you know whether your friend Amira
Abbas is still alive
and how did you feel when your other
friend cadiz a sultana died it was a big
shock because it was at the beginning of
when we left or maybe a year after we
left it wasn't something I suspected it
just came as a really big shock like now
if I had that Amira was dead I wouldn't
be supply I would be her I'll be asleep
I wouldn't be surprised because of the
situation she's doing when Cadiz and I
the situation was still good in Raqqa
you know do you feel that you have made
a mistake do you think you've made a
mistake when you look back at what
you've been through over the last four
years staking going back to the NGO
going to Dola yes a mistake in coming
here living under Islamic state
in a way yes but I don't regret because
I it's changed me as a person it's made
me stronger tougher
[Music]
I married my husband I wouldn't find
someone like him back in the UK I had my
kids you know I did have a good time
there she said and things got hard and I
couldn't take anymore
have you had any contact with your
husband does he know that you have had a
child no I don't have to get in contact
with I don't know if they'll let me gain
contact with him I know where he is
right now I would like to gain contact
have consular officials from the British
government being in touch with you have
you had a phone call from them are you
able to see the news the coverage
centering on you
are you aware just getting in contact
with my family was difficult I just feel
lucky I guess you have had some contact
with them have you lost journalists that
came he contacted my family for me
again is there anything that you would
like to tell them do you have a message
for them please don't give up on trying
to get me back I really don't stay here
must have been a terrible shock for then
when you left because I first obviously
they did try no they did try and ask me
to come back by kept saying know them
and then often was they gave up and I'm
kind of after four years I'm asking them
for help now it's kind of
except in the face to them
what would you say to them I'm sorry
and
your future
do you feel that
there is the possibility of a good
future for you and your your son yes if
the UK are willing to
take me back and
helped me start a new life again
destroy move on already who has happened